after 25 months westworld is back and
once again i'm like the hell is going on
here with a completely new direction
some fun cameos from past characters and
lots of hints at where the show may be
headed i'll be breaking the episode down
with brand new theories and details you
missed we're gonna get right into it but
before we do make sure to like and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of my westworld videos this is las vegas
in the year 2066 that is if we're to
believe this is eight years after the
events of season three which i argue in
my season 3 timeline video occurred in
the year 2058. this is a view from the
mansion of an unnamed cartel member
whose house is furnished in lots of
black and whites this color dichotomy is
something that has been used throughout
all four seasons of westworld from
things as silly as dolores having to
choose the color of her shoes to
william's younger and older versions not
much is known about this cartel member
other than he's a negotiator for a
company which has data william sorely
needs remember that this william is most
likely a host copy controlled by
charlotte hale we saw this in the season
3 post credit scene where it's revealed
charlotte has made a copy of william
using all the data from when he was the
man in black in westworld so basically a
super violent piece of [ __ ] copy this
host goes on to slit the real williams
throat it might be this exact copy that
arrives in this delos drone basically
confirming he's working with charlotte
but remember everything on westworld
isn't always what it seems william is
here to purchase everything this cartel
owns including the hoover dam which
powers row after row of what appears to
be servers there's this really
interesting line where it's mentioned
the generators here can last a hundred
years without needing maintenance
hinting that we're going to see a
significant time jump in the episodes to
come in the season 4 trailer which i'll
leave a link to in the description we
see william in front of the dam with a
giant tear in the middle reminiscent of
the tear we saw in season 2 which led
the host to the sublime a sort of garden
of eden for hosts who could live freely
away from humans there's also some sort
of battle that takes place between
charlotte and yet to be determined
characters so this cartel was paid to
store this encrypted data by someone who
williams says is dead maybe this is
dolores we saw delores's memory wiped at
the end of season 3. yet a version of
her named christina currently lives in
new york new york it seems is some sort
of park run by charlotte we hear these
guys talk about it being their first
time this is way better than i expected
this place is [ __ ] wild i can't
believe this is your first time we also
see charlotte controls the park from
this tower something that is mentioned
throughout the episode
the tower can you see it
so if william is working for charlotte
to obtain data dolores stole how come a
dolores copy is living in charlotte's
park in the season trailer we see
william attached to cables similar to
those dolores was hooked up to in
rehoboam however charlotte talks to him
here as if he's human listen to this
your kind made a sport out of hunting us
you controlled our every move
and now
i'm going to do the same to you is this
the real william who survived the throat
slashing from the trailer we know there
are multiple copies of william could one
of them turn on charlotte after all
before william ventured off to dubai to
kill charlotte he made a vow to
eradicate every last host from the
planet love this floor here which kind
of looks like the maze we'll see this
image in one of maeve's flashbacks and
it also being something bernard searches
for in the trailers so the cartel isn't
too keen on selling all their stuff so
william gives them an ultimatum sell
today and become insanely rich or sell
tomorrow for nothing when the cartel guy
goes home he's attacked by a swarm of
flies and falls unconscious awaking the
next day killing his boss and signing
over everything to william in the intro
credits we see a fly being created so
it's safe to say these are robotic and
controlled by william even when the guy
is walking you can hear these kind of
mechanical robotic sounds perhaps the
flies can seep into someone's mind and
control them another theory is that the
flies kill the host steal their
consciousness and are replaced with a
host copy that can be controlled flies
go all the way back to the very first
scene of westworld season 1 where they
hover over a beat-up dolores in new york
city dolores or should i say christina
wakes up in a similar shot to that found
in season one the name christina is an
interesting choice derived from christ
will she become a savior-like figure she
does choose the white shoes after all
her room is furnished with an easel and
painting we know dolores loved to paint
suggesting that christina is some sort
of iteration of her christina is
harassed by someone we'll come to know
as peter we don't know much about him
other than he believes christine are
responsible for the bad things in his
life and that she's the one who can
change it perhaps this has something to
do with where she works olympiad
entertainment the logo looks a lot like
that of dello so just like delos had at
westworld park maybe olympiad is somehow
involved in this new york park olympiad
could be a rebranding of delos
destinations which face some really bad
press after the massacre at the
westworld park christina's job is a
writer crafting stories for a
quote-unquote video game at least that's
what she thinks she's doing maybe her
job is more akin to that of lee
sizemores where she's actually writing
different storylines for the park's
hosts peter being one of them olympiad
seems to be all-encompassing here in new
york even christina's phone has the
olympiad logo on it the street lights
look eerily like that tower which also
resembles the spindles used to create
hosts christina lives above a shop
called the warehouse which i found a bit
interesting since the humans in
westworld at the mesa lived above a
warehouse containing old hosts at work
christina is told by her boss to stop
writing romance storylines and focus on
what the people want thrills violence
and sex she had been writing a story
about a woman who lived with her father
but dreamed of a bigger life basically a
story analogous to hers and her father
peter abernathy in westworld her boss
tells her to write stories like the one
she wrote several months ago about a guy
who loses everything drowns in his
sorrow stalks some girl and ends up
dying this is our one clue that what
christina wrote actually came true with
this guy peter notice how this gold orb
here and black one here look a lot like
those pearls put in the host's brains in
a secluded cabin maeve looks as though
she's meditating we see her reaching for
something as she experiences several
flashbacks one involves her and her
daughter in the center of the maze
hector clementine and caleb but it's the
caleb stuff that is super interesting we
see the two of them infiltrating the
facility that looks eerily like the one
sorak and liam dempsey senior use to
house early versions of rehoboam they
plant explosives and caleb is seriously
injured this looks like it could be
deadly so is this a flashback or a flash
forward anything seems to be possible in
westworld her tapping into this energy
short-circuits the radio and cuts the
power for not only her generator but the
entire town a disruption that is picked
up by a group of men sent over by
william to track her down leading them
is a man maeve calls colonel brigham who
you may remember as the leader of the
confederados in season 2. so it looks as
though william has a group of hosts in
the real world sent to track down and
kill both maeve and caleb another one of
these henchmen is walter who you might
remember from season one he's been sent
to kill caleb speaking of which caleb is
back to his dull life of construction
work remember how he had a robot buddy
in season three well robots seem to be
nothing but scrap now after humans have
won some sort of war against the
machines apparently those riots we saw
in season 3 helped bring about the
downfall of man's reliance on machines
caleb also has a wife and child frankie
who we see here shooting tin cans a
metaphor for killing hosts in the
trailers we see her as a host with flies
coming out of her mouth we don't know if
frankie has been copied or if his actual
daughter is a host i love this banksy
inspired graffiti here that says my
brain my choice it shows a robot
controlling a human controlling a
robotic drone maybe this is a hint that
humans think they're in control of the
robots but in reality they are the ones
being controlled of note here is this
scar along caleb's face something he did
not have at the end of season three
there's also some cheeky dialogue here
from caleb's wife who tells him
enough with the cowboy [ __ ] after maeve
successfully jack torrance's colonel
brigham she taps into his memory to see
who is after her it's william there's
also an unknown man beside him who we
never really get to see perhaps this is
the senator maeve makes reference to at
the end of the episode seven years off
grid maeve finally puts a torch to her
cabin and sets off in search of caleb
back in new york christina is startled
when she hears a noise on the balcony
venturing outside to find a pitcher of
the maze knowing who ends up arriving at
the end of the episode it's a safe bet
this was put here by teddy and totally
unrelated but i wanted to throw it out
there we don't know when these new york
scenes take place could we be further
into the future than the caleb storyline
westworld has been known to play these
time tricks on us just like they did
with william's storyline in season 1.
christina ends up going on a date with a
guy who tells her maybe you just haven't
found the right man yet foreshadowing
teddy's arrival cristina also makes
reference to the world being broken on
her way home she is stalked by peter who
wants to know why she keeps doing this
to us is this us referring to humanity
he asked how she knew so much about them
which may be a reference to how rehoboam
knew pretty much everything about
everyone whatever the case may be it
seems whatever she wrote ended up coming
true for him and this will result in him
taking his own life in front of her but
before we get to that he attacks and
cuts her arm but during the attack
christino looks away for a brief second
and the man has disappeared yet her cut
is still there if i were to hazard a
guest christina was paused here while
park operators handled the situation in
the season trailer we see how people in
new york can be paused just like the
hosts in westworld christina will wake
up almost identical to the shot we saw
earlier in the episode leading me to
believe she might be in a loop just like
she was in westworld caleb's wife is
concerned about his well-being his ptsd
is so bad he sees threats everywhere and
now this is rubbing off on their
daughter she even believes that he
misses war and that his life here is too
ordinary this all hints at his decision
to join maeve and end this war once and
for all he won't be able to keep his
family safe so long as people like
william are coming after him his wife
says a pretty damning line of
foreshadowing here you're gonna get
yourself killed so it'll be interesting
to see where caleb and maeve's journey
leads them we know there is some sort of
other park set in the 1920s or 30s which
i absolutely can't wait for the final
scene involves christina talking about
how she's searching for something to
fill this emptiness inside her that
thing she needs just might be teddy now
we haven't seen teddy since season 2 in
which he killed himself in front of
dolores and accused her of turning him
into a monster just how he's come back
we aren't sure however i think this
teddy could have the final missing
dolores pearl remember at the end of
season 2 charlotte hale who was secretly
a copy of dolores smuggled out five
copies of herself if you include the
charlotte who escaped this makes six
pearls to account for let's take a look
at who has them the charlotte hale who
escaped westworld who would then
transfer her pearl into the body of
dolores a new charlotte hale martin
connells musashi and bernard this leaves
one left over now to make things more
confusing the original five copies are
all black but in season three episode
three we see the bernard pearl is what's
called a hybrid with black and red mixed
together so either this was a simple
production design mistake or there's a
lot more going on here that we simply
don't know yet we also saw teddy in the
sublime a result of dolores uploading
him there at the end of season 2. with
william seeing this tear at the hoover
dam similar to the one hosts used to
travel to the sublime is it possible
teddy made it back from the sublime
likely not considering teddy killed
himself to get away from her why would
he be seeking her out so that's it for
this episode of westworld i hope you'll
give this video a like and subscribe and
leave a comment on your theories below
thanks for watching everyone you can
follow me on twitter and instagram think
story yt and until next time remember
now be a dear